all right here with reaction Fox News
contributor Dr Janet Nashua was with us
along with this guy came that close as a
republican in the liberal state of New
York to becoming Governor uh former U.S
congressman ran a great campaign Lee
zeldon good to have you here
governor
look I never played doctor I was a lot
of pressure was brought to bear on me to
tell people what to do with covet and I
refused I'm not a doctor you're the
doctor I told people to take it
seriously they got to look at their own
medical condition history underlying
conditions current medical condition and
then consult with their doctors and make
up their own mind
this is an environmental disaster if you
see dead fish and dead animals you're
not going to convince me that that water
is healthy and that air is safe you're
exactly right Sean I mean this is a
massive environmental disaster that
train was carrying a multitude of
different chemicals and one of those
chemicals is vinyl chloride and this is
listed as a class one level a carcinogen
what that means is it is known to cause
cancer specifically liver damage
leukemia blood cancers breast cancers
and then when you burn it you're going
to get these byproducts those byproducts
as well are very harmful they're
dangerous one of them fasting was used
as a chemical warfare weapon back in
World War one because it causes burning
of the eyes itching of the skin
difficulty breathing and that's what the
residents in the community of East
Palestine are experiencing headache and
dizziness drowsiness rashes and that's
why the EPA needs to be out there on the
ground a lot along with FEMA where is
FEMA the Red Cross should be out there
helping as well and the EPA needs to
also be testing for these byproducts not
just Vinyl chloride and we don't know
what the long-term effects are going to
be uh lee it's great to see you good to
see you can you believe here's a case
where I would want the federal
government to step in this is an
environmental disaster
the people of East Palestine did nothing
wrong they don't know if their water's
safe to drink they don't know if the air
is safe to breathe why is the Biden
Administration shooting at unidentified
objects they don't even know what
they're shooting at 400 000 a shot but
they won't give Aid to the people that
are living in an environmental disaster
and mayor Pete says that it's Trump's
fault they want to blame regulation
changes from years ago as opposed to
taking any responses no rules on the
show yeah
and uh Senator Vance credit to him he
just got there as a senator tip of this
spear he's calling on Norfolk Southern
to be responsible for the cleanup costs
to compensate the people who have been
impacted to make them whole calling out
the bite Administration for being AWOL
mayor Pete for you know wherever he is
right now and uh being present you see
him actually at the sites leading so I
think for other members of Congress
that's what Congressman Bill Johnson's
been out there too but all across the
country this is leadership to step up on
behalf of your constituents Norfolk
Southern didn't want to show up to the
question and answer session probably
concerned about liability concerns and
as far as the bite Administration goes
they don't want to show up to answer the
questions because they're stuck in this
narrative let's just blame Trump for
everything okay the law that that
pothole Pete was referring to you know
was passed in 2015. Donald Trump was not
president at that time so it was
actually Obama and Biden's law that he
was actually referring to
um this to me is simple basic governance
101 isn't it aren't they missing an
opportunity instead of caring or
thinking about a lawsuit how about
taking care making sure the people are
going to be safe moving forward why is
that process missing so there's a saying
in the military I've heard it elsewhere
there's no such thing as problems in
life just challenges and opportunities
and for this Administration their stuck
in this never-ending Democratic National
Convention that's the four years and
we're all stuck living in it there's an
opportunity for them to lead there's
nowhere else in this country that would
be better for President Biden to be for
secretary Buddha judge to be then
on-site leading the people making sure
that the full resources of the federal
government are here to make sure that
you're not stuck in wonderment of
whether or not it's even safe to drink
the water Senator Vince again today he
said in the the Q a with the Press if
the EPA administrator really feels like
this water is good enough to drink
I'd love to see that EPA administrator
come here and actually drink it
themselves I only have about 20 seconds
doctor what are the odds that five years
from now we're going to see long-term
impacts from this that's the
so many unanswered questions my concern
is not just the acute symptoms but the
long-term implications birth defects
neurological problems respiratory
problems so that's why it's important if
you're having any symptoms now to
evacuate knowing what you know now and
you own the home there would you leave
that area I would temporarily leave
until I knew for sure the air the water
the soil and the surfaces were all safe
Governor I just came so close uh anyway
Lee's helden thank you doctor thank you
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else